welcome to top five I'm Heather Roose
and I'm Ayanna weed
last week we covered the best Lord of
the Rings moments so you know what that
means
time to get super negative that's not
entirely fair the Lord of the Rings
movies are incredibly successful and
well-made it's hard to nitpick them a
lot of passion and money went into
bringing a fantastical tale to life but
the fan theories and memes to come out
since their releases do highlight some
of the moments that make you go huh
we've had years and an entire other
trilogy today just them and remember
that even the things we love fondly can
have their problems for this list we
will not be looking at differences
between the book series and movies
that's a whole different debate for a
different time it goes without saying
that there were many changes made to the
story when it was adapted as a film
whether for better or worse these are
the top 5 worst Lord of the Rings
trilogy moments number 5
[Music]
let me start by saying Elijah Wood does
a great job throughout the series his
look is perfect for Frodo he also
constantly commits to his acting choices
which is always the better more
interesting choice than playing it safe
that being said the moments when he's
succumbing to the call of the ring are
weird it's hard not to laugh when
they're overly done and incredibly
suggestive part of the problem is when
the beautiful wide shot cuts immediately
to an extreme close-up shot which it's
visually abrupt this happens other times
throughout the movies but it feels
really manipulative with Frodo and the
ring this editing forces the audience's
emotion to flip with the camera to
literally be taken towards the ring for
some people maybe it does work but for
the rest of the time the audience wants
to know why Frodo and Sam desperately
just need to bang already this is of
course one of the pickiest criticism on
our list so let's not dwell here too
long
number four with a saga like Lord of the
Rings characters have to be simplified
however somewhere in this process Gimli
completely lost to any sense of
personality instead he is reduced to the
comic relief the Sochi book is
particularly good salted pork I
understand that someone needs to fill
this kind of role in a tense epic like
this but really in the Fellowship it
wasn't too bad he was a little
bullheaded but he had honor and valor as
the movies progressed he just got
stupider
he became a caricature no longer a noble
member of the Fellowship of the Ring now
just here to make jokes before more
people are sent to their deaths number
three
go home
Frodo and Sam share a bond even before
the journey to destroy the Ring begins
they are seen as inseparable companions
many times they put their lives on the
line for each other throughout the
journey to Mount Doom their relationship
grows even deeper so the event that
finally breaks them apart should be epic
and heart-rending right nope
Gollum convinces Frodo that Sam has
eaten all the lambis bread with no more
evidence than some crumbs and insults
with a fat stupid Hobbit honestly I
don't even know how the crumbs Gollum
planted on Sam stayed there from there
things get heated fast Sam attacks
column then Frodo is convinced that Sam
is trying to steal the ring and boom
friendship over now listen I understand
that carrying the ring can cause the
wearer to experience negative feelings
and paranoia but I don't think it would
have been enough to destroy their
relationship especially given that golem
has spent the majority of his time with
Sam and Frodo trying to steal the ring
and trick them why would Frodo even
trust him to begin with because he also
used to hold the ring and understands
what he's going through I guess but it
still seems to come out of nowhere there
didn't need to be any added drama in
this relationship I'm pretty sure the
epic quest to destroy the ultimate
weapon in a literal mountain of doom is
drama enough number two
Edwin's life is now tied to the fate
doesn't ring for a franchise that just
loves exposition and long-winded
explanations of things there is
literally no reason given for this chain
of events Ottawa is dying
you'll not long survive the evil that
now spreads from Mordor out of nowhere
we see that Arwen's life and fate are
tied to the ring the exact wording here
is the light of the Evenstar is failing
the serums power grows her strength
wanes first of all I'm not even 100%
sure what this means yes we know that
she is choosing to become mortal to be
with Aragorn but this has nothing to do
with that it's not like every mortal in
middle-earth is now dying due to saurons
power second how did this happen we
never saw Arwen have any interactions
with Sauron so there's no opportunity
for their fates to be linked this isn't
even a case of they explain it better in
the book because this isn't even in the
book it serves no purpose or reason I am
glad that Peter Jackson and the writers
tried to incorporate our win into the
story more she is an interesting
character and this universe needed a
couple more ladies but that almost makes
it even worse
why choose to give a character a bigger
role than in the books and then reveal
that she's dying the audience true to
care for her so to just give her this
random and pending death was confusing
and angering
[Music]
laughs I see
and the number one worst Lord of the
Rings trilogy moment is
[Music]
there were many characters we met along
the way we've grown fond of more than
just Frodo and Sam's plight in the end
there's an instinctual need to satisfy
all the viewers and not just the ones
who read the books
just kidding still here we could have
gotten just the fate of the Ring or even
the fate of the king but we were given
everything tied up in a beautiful bow
well multiple bowls in different
packages that we thought were done
wrapping and then whoops there's another
gift
fade to black roll credits now nope
fade to white oh oh okay and another
ending what's so frustrating about
criticizing the multiple endings is that
it really just feel like complaining
about getting too many presents the
multiple endings certainly serve their
purpose are well made and emotionally
satisfying okay except for the hobbits
frolicking on the bed they're small
grown men not literal children just a
room full of dudes having a pajama party
nothing to see here
after the decade we spent watching the
trilogy okay maybe it was barely over 11
hours but it still felt like it we
deserve a solid ending the figure of
each conclusion weakens the affer
mentioned accomplishments audiences
continually feel the resolution only to
get another wrap-up and can't help but
wonder when the credits are gonna roll
for 20 minutes it felt drawn out rather
than fulfilling and that's just not how
you want to actually end this long
emotional journey we want to hear what
you guys think what is your least
favorite Lord of the Rings moment what
do you want us to cover next on the show
we have a comment and let us know to
keep in touch you can find me on
Facebook Twitter or Instagram and you
can find me on Twitter Instagram or
twitch where I stream on Wednesday
nights if you liked our lists make sure
that you check out the nostalgia critic
as he looks at the top 11 dumbest Lord
of the Rings moments even though there
were some things that we agreed on here
there were others we just didn't have
time to mention so go give it a watch
we'll catch you right back here next
week on a brand new episode at
five
[Music]
[Applause]
you